today on the matt wall show there's been
a lot of talk in recent weeks about
breaking up the country having a
national divorce today i'll make my case
for secession but also i'm gonna explain
why i think it'll probably never happen
also five headlines including biden
hacking and coughing and wheezing his
way through a speech how long before
president harris officially takes over
also another business owner stands up
against tyrannical health inspectors and
inmates at a jail in pennsylvania
complain that they're being persecuted
by the dinner menu plus our daily
cancellation and much more today on the
matt walsh show
[Music]
[Applause]
well you know if you have a family as i
do we all want to take care of our
families right
and we all we think about the things
that our families need on a day-to-day
basis
maybe you haven't thought much about
life insurance that's one
really important way to take care of
your family something to really think
about
as we get into the holidays the problem
though is that in holiday season
especially it can really sort of lighten
your wallet
uh gets very expensive so for many
families december is one of the most
expensive months of the year
not to mention the busiest if you need
life insurance but you don't want to
deal with the hassle or the expense
especially right now then i would
recommend policy genius policygenius.com
combined combines a cutting-edge
insurance marketplace with help from
license experts
to save you time and money right now you
could save 50
or more by using policy genius to
compare life insurance
and you're shopping for a policy that
could last for more than a decade you
know those those savings really start to
add up they're talking about a lot of
money you could save over time
uh starting right away so first head to
policygenius.com in minutes you can work
out how much coverage you need
you can compare quotes from top insurers
they're going to make all that really
easy for you
and once you apply the policy genius
team will handle all the paperwork all
the red tape
so you don't have to worry about that it
can seem like a daunting challenge to
deal with that well they're going to do
it
and they're going to save you a lot of
money this kind of service it's what has
earned policy genius a five-star rating
across
over 1600 reviews on trustpilot and
google you can go check that out for
yourself
but in the meantime if you have loved
ones who depend on your income
don't go into 2021 without life
insurance go to policygenius.com and get
started
you could save 50 or more by comparing
quotes and you can start the new year
with one less thing to worry about
and also knowing that you're taking care
of your family policy genius
when it comes to insurance it's nice to
get it right you know it's always better
i think to frame
political conversations within the
context of reality and so we should
begin by acknowledging that in reality
there will almost certainly be no
serious move towards secession or
national divorce
the civil war has already settled the
question of whether states will be
allowed to
peacefully secede notice i don't say
that the civil war settled the question
of whether
states ought to be able to secede i
believe
they should and do have such a right a
union held together merely by the fact
that the united
parties are compelled to unity by force
is no true union at all in my opinion
you know a man might prevent his wife
from leaving him
by locking her in the basement but as
soon as the marriage requires kidnapping
to be maintained
it's effectively nullified already the
civil war established
that states will not be allowed to leave
without a fight to the death
not that they have no right to leave now
many people argue that the civil war
showed that states cannot leave for a
bad reason like to maintain slavery
i would agree that slavery is a bad
thing and a bad reason to succeed but
there shouldn't be any authority
above the individual state which gets to
decide whether that state's reason for
leaving is permissible or not
the wife may have a bad reason for
leaving her husband
but there couldn't be any reason that
justifies kidnapping besides the yanks
weren't marching down south to kill the
rebs to stop them
from dissolving the union over slavery
they were marching to stop them from
dissolving the union
period the north didn't decide that the
war was about freeing the slaves until
many thousands were already laying dead
on the battlefield
lincoln put it on the record that he was
determined to preserve the union
whether that meant keeping slavery or
abolishing it either way
but to the victor goes to spoils and one
spoil in this case
is a fundamental shift mutation some
would say
in the way we define union on a national
level
once we were states freely bonded
together through mutual consent now we
are property
of the federal government maintained in
our union by the fact
that we'll probably be killed if we try
to leave it so
there will be no divorce or secession
now without war and as for war
i really don't think that a country
hooked on netflix binges video games
fast food has the will or the interest
to fight a war
on their own soil i mean at the end of
the day we all want to be at home in our
sweatpants watching reruns of the office
and waiting for the doordash guy to
bring us our carton of kung pao chicken
or maybe that's just me i don't know
anyone who studied the civil war
at all knows that it was if nothing else
a horrific period in our history when
men suffered greatly and died horribly
because they wanted something badly and
believed in their cause deeply
we are just too apathetic and too
risk-averse
to willingly embrace those horrors again
whether that's a good or bad thing
is a debate for another time that's the
reality
depressing as it may be but putting
reality to the side
it's worth thinking about what should
happen now it seems certain that the
country
will not break apart but should it you
know imagining for a moment that it were
possible for states to leave the union
without two percent of the population
dying again in a cataclysmic war of
attrition
would that be for the best out of all
the possible paths forward
would secession be the most preferable
if also the least plausible
i think so if divorce were possible
it should be what we elect to do the
reason as i've argued many times in the
past
is that we're already divorced in every
way but officially the left and right
and these groups themselves are
splintered especially on the right
have a wide and impassable gulf between
them
they have nothing in common even at the
most basic level no shared priorities
beliefs goals values
we might as well be living in different
galaxies you know if i
wanted to meaningfully unite with
someone who believes that
america is systemically racist babies
aren't people
men have uteruses the police should be
defunded prefer socialism over
capitalism
i wouldn't know how you know i i can't
relate to such a person on any level at
all
so unite around what by what through
what
we have nothing in common we share
nothing except maybe a language but even
that's not guaranteed these days
we used to share at least a handful of
cultural traditions but
those have all been rendered political
and quote problematic
we don't have the deeper and more
fundamental commonalities neither do we
have the more superficial
which means we have nothing to bind us
together at all except the simple fact
that we are bound that's not how i want
it to be but it's how it is
if secession and separation are not our
fate and as i said they probably won't
be then what else
the preferability of divorce becomes
clearer when you consider the other
options
which so far as i can tell can be boiled
down to three possibilities i think
if it's not succession then then here
are the three
paths that we may go from here number
one
we could have indefinite stalemate and
stagnation
uh this is the possibility that ross
douthit if that's how you pronounce his
name i can never quite figure it out
explores in the decadent society a book
that you know just published a few
months ago which i would recommend
he argues that we're doomed for a while
at least to drift along
aimlessly in political and cultural
stalemate not collapsing
catastrophically but also not achieving
or advancing in any particular
direction i tend to agree that this is
what's happening and probably will
continue happening but i wouldn't choose
it
it's not the best path even if it's the
most likely the bible says that christ
will
spit the lukewarm out of his mouth it's
sort of horrifying to think that my
children
will inherit a lukewarm civilization
sputtering along
not hot or cold neither dead nor alive
heading neither toward ruin nor glory
number two other possibility escalating
violence and unrest
recent events may point to this
possibility for a while
leftist radicals reigned terror in our
cities unopposed
basically now they're being met with
force could continue like this getting
bloodier and more brutal
never turning into a full-scale
organized war but
causing untold death and damage all the
same
and then number three there could be
unity that's possible
but through submission see there's
always the possibility that division
will give way to unity
but this can't happen through compromise
as there is no middle ground
between two diametrically opposed views
of life and reality
i can't meet someone halfway when they
argue in favor of giving
hormones to physically healthy children
or insist that it's automatically racist
for white police officers to shoot
violent black suspects where's the
halfway point on those issues
or any of the other ones that separate
us what's the halfway point between
theism and atheistic nihilism
how do i compromise with a worldview
that defines itself by its opposition to
my own
it would seem that the only way to
achieve unity would be for one side or
the other to surrender
there's a great gulf between us and
nowhere to meet within that gap
but one side could abandon its post and
just join the other
the problem is that given our cultural
trajectory and the thorough hold the
left has on the youngest generations i
don't see them abandoning their post
anytime soon
so if any side is going to give up the
ghost in the coming decades
i have to admit that it's probably more
likely to be the one that i'm on
and that's an option that i find
infinitely more horrifying and
undesirable
than secession these would seem to be
the three possible doors that our
civilization could open and walk through
right now we're sort of standing in the
foyer wavering between these options
getting a taste of all three
the fourth the door to secession and
national divorce is way off to the side
not being seriously considered by enough
people to make it a plausible option at
this point but i firmly believe
it would be for the best america has
never been a nation bonded together by
one shared religion or ethnicity
but we did once share a creed
however imperfectly we lived by it we no
longer have that creed in common
or really anything else in common
it's sad uh it's not what i want
but it's the truth and i wish that now
we can all acknowledge it
go our separate ways once and for all
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
well anyway now that i just explained
why uh the country should
should divorce and break apart um let's
get to i i did want to mention something
on a lighter
note um totally unrelated but i
uh i was just thinking about it because
i was reading something on twitter
someone lecturing uh truck drivers
saying that truck drivers are
you know just there's no excuse to drive
a truck and cars are getting so much
bigger now and it's a big problem and
we're destroying the environment
and i i i i say they're lecturing truck
drivers i can say we truck drivers now
because i bought my first
pickup truck which i was very excited
about uh last week
i just bought it and something very
strange has happened now this was not
cultural appropriate i know i just moved
to tennessee and buying a pickup truck
it seems like cultural appropriation
it's not exactly
i mean i always had in mind that i
wanted one we decided let's go ahead and
get it
this very weird thing happened though
and i'm not i'm not even making this up
this is really i can't explain it it's
like a scientific
phenomenon but i've always i've never
been a fan of country music
i've always hated it actually just
viscerally
but i got the pickup truck and now i've
noticed that it sounds
sort of good now in the truck i'm
actually find myself listening to
country music
i don't know what it is it's just that's
the secret you have to listen to it in a
truck
and uh the only thing i do now i guess
is the cowboy boots all right we're
gonna move on number one joe biden gave
a speech yesterday
after the electoral college vote um
but the headline for me wasn't anything
that he said rather it was the way he
struggled mightily to say it
let's uh let's take a listen to that and
once again
the american america the rule of law
more americans voted this year
than have ever voted in the history of
the united states the votes counted
and pence received when they won in
2016.
excuse me or dispute
the results margin four years ago
and yet i thank them and i'm convinced
we can work together for the good of the
nation
on many subjects that's the duty owed to
the people
to our constitution to our history
you know in this battle for the soul of
america
democracy prevailed we the people voted
faith in our institutions held the
integrity of our elections remains
intact
and now it's time to turn the page as
we've done throughout our history
to unite to heal as i said in this
campaign
i will be president for all americans
i'll work just as hard for those of you
who didn't vote for me
as i will for those who did there's
urgent work in front of us
getting this pandemic under control and
getting the nation vaccinated
against this virus yeah there is urgent
work i'm just
wondering if he's going to be around for
it
uh i mean you could say it's it's it's
unfair
something like that i mean ev maybe he
has a cold or something and
anyone that's experienced public
speaking we've all been in that
situation before where your voice is
giving out and uh it's it's it's
it's not fun but it does it does
obviously it
just brings to mind the concern that
we've got this 78 year old man
uh who's already physically
deteriorating and mentally deteriorating
who's going to be in the white house
uh i i guess now we just you know
[Music]
it's always been clear to me that
there's there's no way we get to
um 2024 and joe biden is still
in the white house as president so it's
just i guess now it's just a question of
how long will it be
my prediction is this is what i would
predict
you could take this to the bank actually
don't because my political predictions
are pretty much always wrong so
don't listen to this at all but i'm
going to say it my prediction would be
that within about six it'll take six
months not for
joe biden to step down but within six
months
there will be very audible and public
calls
from people on the left that he should
think about
stepping down i would say they're going
to wait because that this is their plan
all along of course
this this is inevitable that they're
going to leaks make that call because
they want to get
they want to get kamel harris in there i
would say they'll probably wait
six months and then the calls will start
how long will it be before joe biden
actually does step to the side
uh i don't know but i it's it's really
hard for me to see him
making it all the way to 2024 the age of
82.
as i've been saying all along even if he
wasn't just
just about to take on the most stressful
job on earth
and he was just retired sitting in his
rocking chair on the porch
i would still say you know i don't know
if he's going to be
you know with us in four years but
considering he's taking on the most
stressful job and he's not going to be
sitting on his porch in a rocking chair
um and he is going to have to come out
of his basement uh
it just makes it all the all the more
clear to me
so what happens i guess we're going to
discover this
if the president is completely
incapacitated are they going to tell us
that
um how long before they tell us
i guess we'll find out number two big
news today about
pornhub we've been following this story
here's the article in the verge
it says pornhub is removing all videos
uploaded to its site
by unverified users millions of videos
in total as part of a crackdown
on user uploaded content after two major
payment processors suspended service
um the decision first reported by
motherboard stems for a new york times
report that found the site was hosting
videos of people who are
underage and videos showing children
being assaulted
well yeah the new york times found that
but uh that that
that's oh it's been known that this this
is not news
um if anyone's been paying attention the
site announced last tuesday that would
begin
limiting uploads to verified users only
um
it appears that pornhub has wiped out
more than 10 million videos as of this
writing
and i don't see the percentage here
listed but what i saw
online was it was like 50 or 60 percent
of the content has been wiped out which
is great i mean it's it's progress
now again i i would for me what i would
prefer to see happen what i ultimately
would like to see happen
is that pornhub is shut down and his
executives are marched to prison
and locked in cages in prison for the
rest of their lives that i think is the
ultimate goal um that's what i would
love to see happen
that's what should happen i mean when
you when you make billions
monetizing child rape i don't think you
should be able to say
oh my bad sorry and just start taking it
down
and then go about your merry way and i
don't think that's how it should happen
i think there should be real
consequences
for it but um this is a step in the
right direction
the only point here like we talked about
last week when
we were discussing this issue is that
pornhub again
is a multi-billion dollar porn
aggregator
that has that has monetized child rape
and
and other forms of of evil degeneracy
and that's how they've made a living
that's how they've made their money
which means
you can't trust them so any any amount
of self-regulating you can't trust it
the question now is oh we're only going
to allow it from verified users well
what does that mean
so they're making this big show of
purging everything doing this after
remember
last week initially when the report came
out they said oh there's no problem what
are you talking about everything's fine
you know we're we're reviewing every
video and we've got
procedures in place now they're turning
around and wiping out 10 million videos
turns out there was a problem
which only goes to show you can't trust
them so uh verified users what does that
mean
from what i read a website called fight
the new drug which is an anti-porn
watchdog
what they say is that the process for
getting verified on pornhub
all that means is that you take a
picture you write your name and your
birth date
or maybe not even your birthday i think
you just write your name down on a piece
of paper
or somewhere on your body and you take a
picture and you send it in
okay that's
more than nothing but it's not a lot
more than nothing
and it seems to me that someone could
still be underage and do that
or they could still go through that
verification process
and then upload a video that features an
underage person or someone who's not
consenting
so this is a step in the right direction
it's not as big a step as it seems
number three here's a another video that
you both love and hate to see you hate
to see it because it's another
business owner being persecuted by
tyrannical bureaucrats you love to see
it because it's also another business
owner
refusing to take it lying down we'll
play a bit of this exchange this is the
owner of nick the greek restaurant
in i believe california dealing with the
a public health inspector who's come to
the business
to further harass and extort him and uh
here's how that exchange went
in the rules my tables are inside just
because the health department
has the whole process to go through that
takes however long
that takes i have proposed my business
for that time who's
are you gonna pay my rent are you gonna
pay my rent can you charge to make those
decisions
i chose to protest by putting my tables
outside and i reiterated again i never
served one single person outside
i could all take out food and delivery
to what exactly i was supposed to be
doing
that's exactly what i did i did not
break any and there was no
law i did not bring any rule there
there is a lot that you're breaking
right now by operating without a comment
i because you guys put this closure on
my restaurant
right so you you guys yourselves are
creating your own rule
and you're getting my citation for your
own rule that's created it's not my law
that you cannot sit outside and eat
that's not law that's what it's an order
that was given
that that exchange uh you can go online
and find that exchange goes on for a
while
that's just a part of it there and
every bit of pushback and anger
that he is directing towards these
people is
deserved and i've seen some some people
online i guess
trying to be uh trying to be gracious
i think far too gracious saying well
uh you know these public health
inspectors they're doing their job and
maybe they don't want to be doing it
either and
they're you know it's not up to them
they're just enforcing the rules
um no this is this is a you know i was
following orders kind of excuse
these people these bureaucrats showing
up
to these businesses i don't care if
they're following orders or not
i don't care if they set the rules or
not um
that's no excuse and they deserve every
bit of
derision and hatred and everything that
they that they get
contempt that's directed at them
because you're at a point right now
where if if this if this is your job
then you need to step down and say i'm
not going to do this job
no it's not an easy thing to do it's
easy for me to say but
that's the right choice when you're in a
job and someone tells you okay go to
this business owner
and uh you know harass them for just
trying to conduct their business
go in fact go into this business and try
to find
something they're doing wrong so that
you can
find them even when they're already in
the midst of a financial
crisis because that's what these people
are doing
they're just going in looking for a
problem
that's when if you're a decent good
person that's when you say
uh no you could take this job and shove
it because i'm not going to do it
all right number four deborah messing
as an actress she got herself in the hot
water when she said that she she hopes
trump goes to prison
and becomes quote the most popular
boyfriend in prison
this this got her into hot water because
now only
only because it's homophobic allegedly
to to say that
um she wasn't in hot water for you know
wishing this on the president it was
just
the comment that she made people were
saying even some people on the left were
saying that's homophobic
uh well to combat this claim that she's
anti-gay she posted a clarification
and it may be one of the strangest
clarifications
in history i don't know here's what she
says
let me be clear i said nothing about the
lgbtqi slash queer love
wait hold up i said nothing about lgbtqi
queer love okay rape is an act of
violence
trump has perpetrated violence on
hundreds of millions of people
my hope is and this is the first time in
my life
that the tables are turned and he is the
victim of perpetrators
hashtag lgbtqi ally
so here's what she's saying no no no no
guys you misunderstood me
oh you thought i said something
offensive no no no no no no i
i was only saying i hope the president
is raped that's all i was trying to say
that's it
uh and i like how she clarifies this is
the first time this is the first time in
my life i've ever wished rape on someone
this is my first time all right we all
we we all we all wish it sometimes on
people
this is my first time she really
and she thinks that that's that's enough
like she she really doesn't understand
this is this is a lot of people on the
left
they really don't see the problem like
she's actually surprised that people
have a problem with it
she can't understand she's saying what
i'm just i'm just
wishing violence and sexual violation on
my political enemies what do you mean
these people aren't even they're not
even people
of course i can do that and that's how
they see that's how they see not only
trump but
but all conservatives all right let's go
finally number five controversy and
outrage surrounding
alleged mistreatment of inmates at the
allegheny county jail in pennsylvania
one inmate had a video call with his
aunt and i guess
this is something you can do in jail now
you can have video calls
news to me but uh he had a video called
this on and he showed what he'd been
served for dinner
and he requested that she make it go
viral and she did
and it's uh being been a big controversy
especially in pennsylvania
here's the video watch this is the
dinner that they're serving us in the
jail tonight
which is bologna with apple sauce in it
and teddy grams
that's the only thing that's on our tray
for dinner tonight no juice no
vegetables no fruit
no nothing i want you to make this go
viral honestly you hear me
this is our dinner right here make sure
you take a picture too senators send it
out
and put it on us all over social media
put it all over the internet this is not
dinner
for tonight they're not giving us our
fruits and vegetables they're not giving
us our protein or anything this is
warm baloney right here in applesauce
with a little pack of teddy grams that's
our trade for dinner tonight
but they're telling us to deal with it
or eat that's what they're telling us
tonight
all right now i want you to see this i
want you to send it out on a mass email
whatever you got to do
get it all on social media to the news
and everybody
uh first can i just say
not that that would be a dinner that i
would personally enjoy
um i'm also not in prison you know i'm
not in jail so
i didn't get arrested so i i'm i'm able
to go and buy what i want for dinner
uh i mean you're not an outback
steakhouse here you're you're in jail
uh which is which is you know at least
one step below an outback steakhouse
uh but he says we're not getting our
fruits and protein
what do you mean you got applesauce and
you got you got bologna that's
that's a fruit and protein i don't
really understand the applesauce
in the bologna that part of it it seemed
almost like it was like a it was like a
a baloney burrito with apples like
bologna wrapped around applesauce
i don't know if he did that himself or
if that's what they serve that part of
it i'll admit
is strange but the rest of it my kids
would go
wild if my kids were in jail and they
got that meal they would say i want to
stay in jail forever
my kids would go wild for that meal
um but one other point also to consider
is that
if you know if inmates in a jail are
really being
persecuted in some way or mistreated
probably they couldn't do a video call
complaining about it
i mean the fact that you're served a
meal you're in jail you're served a male
you can do a video call
complaining about it asking your aunt to
complain on social media
and she can do that
that tells me that probably
you're being treated okay maybe even
better
than okay i mean maybe i'm a little
old-fashioned i would say maybe inmates
in jail shouldn't be allowed to do
video calls but uh
but that's just me before we get to our
daily cancellation you know one thing
uh about men is that we can be reluctant
sometimes to go to the doctor
really for any reason i think studies
kind of bear this out and
personal experience bears it out that we
don't like going to the doctor
but that's why it's great that for
hymns.com
is there it's all about men's wellness
if you need help with ed
hair loss if you have a cold whatever it
is if you're interested in mental health
or covid 19 home tests
hymns is here for you through hymns you
can get prescription medication that
treats ed
this is real science real solutions to
ed hims makes it easy hims
connects you with a licensed medical
professional online who can prescribe
fda approved prescription medication to
treat ed you get the same active
ingredient as that expensive little pill
but without
the expensive price tag on top of it you
know this could cost hundreds of bucks
if you have to go through a doctor
pharmacy whatever not with him hims
makes it simple and affordable
there's no embarrassing conversations no
expensive appointments just answer a few
questions online
about your medical history and a
provider will confident confidentially
review it and if approved your
medication is shipped directly to your
door in discreet packaging
and shipping is free why live with ed
when the solution can be this simple
here's what you got to do try hymns
today by starting out with a free online
visit
go to for matt hymns.com your free visit
that's for hims.com matt f-o-r-h-i-m-s
dot com slash matt prescription products
are subject to medical approval
and require an online consultation with
a medical provider who will determine if
a prescription is appropriate see
website for details and safety
information remember
that's for hymns dot com slash matt
also i want to tell you that on monday
december 21st mark this down on the
calendar the historical docu-series
apollo 11 what we saw
will be available exclusively at
dailywire.com originally released as an
audio podcast for apple and spotify
a lot of people listened to that really
enjoyed it i know i did i thought it was
great what we saw will be available
to watch as well as listen on the daily
wire apple tv or roku app
or at dailywire.com the docu series
takes a detailed look at the apollo 11
mission to land a man on the moon
it was the culmination of a heated
decades-long space race between coldwell
rivals
united states and soviet union the
podcast explores that
it's a dramatic inspiring story apollo
11 what we saw is a fantastic series to
watch with
you know you watch it by yourself you
can watch it with your loved ones your
families
over the holiday break and right now you
can get it for 20
off with code watch when you become an
insider or above member over at
dailywire.com
subscribe and make sure to
and downl to all of our new and existing
content
all right let's go to our daily
cancellation
[Music]
now for our daily cancellation it's time
for another of the fabled reverse
cancellations this is uh when i am in
the midst of being canceled myself
yet i managed to break free turn the
tables and cancel the cancellers it's
always very exciting
so today i'm canceling those who are
trying to cancel me
for my take on the cleveland indians who
announced that they'll be changing their
name because the name
indians is offensive somehow to indians
incidentally the cleveland browns
lost last night to the baltimore ravens
on a 55 year old
yard field goal in the final seconds of
the game after lamar jackson the
baltimore ravens quarterback had run
back onto the field after missing half
of the fourth quarter with cramps that
some say
was probably code for he had to use the
bathroom anyway my point is that
i like to think the sports gods were
punishing the city of cleveland for its
cowardice
um not that the city of cleveland really
needs to be punished when it comes to
sports anymore than it already has been
over the last several decades
in any case the indians will not be the
indians anymore uh this news has been
celebrated by those on the left to
assure us that the
native american community never feels
more seen and understood and respected
than when all mention of the native
american community is removed from
popular culture
indeed tmz reports today that native
american leaders expect that the suicide
rate
in that community is going to go down
because the cleveland baseball team has
chosen a different mascot
i'm not making that up that is really
what is being claimed that it's going to
lower the suicide rate i briefly
mentioned this story about the cleveland
baseball team on the show yesterday i
also mentioned it briefly on twitter
in both forums i argued as i have in the
past that
having a team name and a mascot based
around native americans
is no more or less offensive than having
one based on any other group
namely the irish the boston celtics for
example are called the balsa boston
celtics and their mascot is a leprechaun
the fighting irish of notre dame also
have a leprechaun mascot only theirs is
a bit more
ornery this is the point that i posted
on twitter i said
uh quote quoting myself i have never
heard anyone ever complain about the
boston celtics and their stereotypical
mascot if cleveland indian is offensive
then so is this
but this isn't offensive to anyone with
a brain and a shred of
emotional maturity and neither is
cleveland indian
now i must admit i do deserve to be
canceled for this tweet
only because of the typo on then i
spelled it t-h-a-n instead of t-h-e-n
normally i have a policy of deleting all
typo tweets but i couldn't delete this
one because
leftists were mad at it for another
reason so i had to choose between
preserving my dignity and deleting it
because of the typo
or keeping the tweet up in service of
triggering the libs
as george washington once said when
given a choice between triggering the
libs
or not triggering them always trigger
them but much of the outrage
derision mockery etc directed at me is
not over the typo as it should be
but over the point that i'm making a
great many media people especially
sports media
have responded saying just to summarize
here basically they say
oh you idiot that's that's not the same
besides leprechauns are fictional
characters didn't you know that
what do you think the boston celtics is
offensive to leprechauns
got him yes leprechauns are
fictional characters okay then
so you're saying you're saying that's
okay so what you're telling me is that
it's okay to make a team name out of an
ethnic group
as long as the mascot is a make-believe
creature
associated with the traditions and
mythologies of that group
that's what you want to go with okay
well then here's my proposal
let's keep them the cleveland indians
and make their mascot a character from
native american folklore
the lakota for example believed in
forest spirits
who were like magical dwarves living in
the trees
uh ken otilia they called them probably
mispronounced it
is that better make them the indians but
with the magical
dwarf as the mascot sort of like a
leprechaun has that sound
would that be okay oh no no that
wouldn't be
in fact that would be even worse
wouldn't it you'd say it's still a
problem because the name is still
indians and now we've appropriated their
cultural mythology
and turned it into a mascot made a joke
of it
i've also been told that the fighting
irish and the celtics are not offensive
because those team names
are based on the predominant ethnicity
of their fan base
at least historically right a lot of
irish people in boston
okay so that's the rule now a basketball
team can make a group
race or ethnicity into a mascot as long
as it's a race or ethnicity common in
their fan base
something tells me this logic would get
a sports organization into a lot of
trouble
if they tried to apply it to virtually
anyone but the irish
the other excuse i've heard is that it's
different because native americans are
historically persecuted group
unlike the irish who famously have had
an enormously easy ride all through
history right
no of course not the irish have been
persecuted too in this country and their
own
so that excuse doesn't wash either see
when you sift through all of the
arguments for why it's offensive to make
indians into a team name
or a mascot but not the irish
you begin to quickly realize that all
the arguments are utter hogwash
as the kids would say whatever tortured
logic
makes indians or braves offensive must
also apply to drunken leprechaun mascots
to represent teams with
irish and celtic in their name and those
on the left
here's the thing they could quite easily
make their point
achieve their desired end if they simply
said yeah you're right
that's offensive too let's get rid of
that also
but they won't say that they can't say
that
because that would be to admit that
non-white groups
shouldn't get any special consideration
nor do they corner the market on
persecution
nor should we have more respect for them
than we do any other group
it would be to it would be in other
words to treat all groups equally
which is the last thing that anybody on
the left
wants to do but they won't admit that so
they're stuck trying to find differences
where none exist
and ignore them where they do for that
reason
they are canceled not me i'm only
partially canceled for the typo thing
but i'm right about the mascot thing and
let's focus on what i'm right about
today and always that's going to do it
for our
show today thanks for watching everybody
thanks for listening
have a great day godspeed
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
our technical director is austin stevens
production manager pablo vadosky
the show is edited by danny d'amico our
audio is mixed by mike coromina
hair makeup is done by nikka geneva and
production assistant mckenna waters
the matt wall show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2020.
if you prefer facts over feelings aren't
offended by the brutal truth and you can
still laugh at the insanity filling our
national news cycle
well tune in to the ben shapiro show
we'll get a whole lot of that and much
more
see you there